these lions don't know it but the
coronavirus is a danger to them too well
they probably can't get the virus the
pandemic does indirectly threaten their
habitat they live in a nature reserve
Nicholas Koryo normally guides tourists
who come to see endangered animals it's
near Kenya's capital Nairobi the
government suspended international
flights nearly two months ago
no foreign tourists have come here since
it's all a bit worrying because if we
don't
I've only receive like lands in the
country then I'm afraid that lots of
jobs are surely going to be lost
visitors normally eat and sleep in the
camp where Nicholas works
it's hard to temporarily close normally
in camps like this all the beds are
fully booked during the peak seasons
more than 2 million foreign tourists
visited Kenya last year most of them
come here to see the wildlife that lives
in the reserves and the money they spend
creates millions of jobs and provides
crucial funding for conservation the
fees charged for visiting reserves and
camps pay for the salaries of Rangers
who protect animals from poachers the
communities living nearby depend on the
income of those employed in the sector
and if livelihoods are lost people are
forced to find other ways to survive
things like poaching either for you know
household protein supplement or you know
cutting down of trees to serve remain
household income and that is tied to the
harsh economic realities occasioned by
covered 19 the Nairobi reserve is unique
that it sits just on the edge of the
city conservationists say in the long
run if tourism isn't economically viable
Reserve land will be used for farming or
property development instead just
outside the park is a sanctuary for
orphaned animals these walkways are
usually teeming with visiting
schoolchildren
the warden told us educating local
community is key to conserving wildlife
and its environment
most of our domestic tourists come from
our country these are mainly the schools
and the analog are coming because the
schools were closed due to the current
status the revenue again has gone down
nobody here expects things to change
before the coronavirus restrictions are
lifted conservationists say they're
looking for other ways to fund the
reserves so the wildlife within them and
the people around them in her future
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera Nairobi Kenya